I'll ask this question several times in
the past but to no satisfactory answer I
hope this time it works imagine you have
a train moving at 100 miles an hour you
have to train moving at hundred miles an
hour and you have a fly within the train
that moves it two miles an hour with
respect to the train now to another
outside observer the fly seems to be
moving at 102 miles an hour we know it's
not possible is this just a paradox or
does this lead us to understand one of
the loopholes a possible and possible
plausible loophole in relativity it's
it's just my attempt to question
relativity because any theory any
understanding is if no credibility if it
cannot be questioned thank you